Trascrizione: sara liguori
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Per anni ho fatto la sex columnist.
Sex columnist è una persona che scrive di
sesso e relazioni su magazine e riviste.
Lo scopo è quello di distruggere,
smantellare gli stereotipi e i tabù
che da sempre sono interconnessi
alla nostra vita sessuale e di relazione.
Questo lo facciamo scrivendo di sesso,
di porno, di sex toys, di nuove tendenze.
Lo facciamo intervistando
esperti ed esperte,
lo facciamo raccontando le nostre
stesse esperienze.
Lo scopo è quello di normalizzare
la sessualità sana e veritiera,
che è ben diversa da quella
a cui siamo abituati.
Infatti nei film, nel porno,
soprattutto nel porno mainstream
per sentito dire,
la sessualità viene raccontata
come se fosse l’espressione
di una società fatta
e formata da supereroi,
e procede per frasi fatte,
per giochi di ruolo.
Ad esempio, vi ricordate l’incipit
di quel discutibile film
che si chiama “La verità
è che non gli piaci abbastanza”,
in cui un bambino
spinge a terra una bambina,
e lei corre piangendo dalla madre,
e la madre le dice:
“Tranquilla, non ti preoccupare,
se lui l’ha fatto è perché tu gli piaci”.
Ecco, è proprio questo a cui mi riferisco,
è qui che inizia il dramma.
Noi viviamo la sessualità
indossando delle maschere,
e il ruolo di chi scrive di sesso
sui giornali è proprio quello di levarcele
cercando un contatto con chi ci legge
in modo tale da poter smantellare
le credenze che in anni
abbiamo introiettato e le sovrastrutture
che le mantengono.
E sono proprio quelle
che ci fanno da sempre pensare
che gli uomini vengano da Marte
e le donne da Venere.
Anche io avevo introiettato
un sacco di cose,
tant’è che la prima volta
in cui mi hanno proposto un lavoro
come sex columnist
per un giornale maschile,
mi sono chiesta: “Una donna che parla
di sesso agli uomini funzionerà?
Parleremo la stessa lingua?
Avremo un punto di contatto?
Riusciremo a sviluppare
reciproca fiducia?”
Ecco, io tutti questi dubbi me li portavo
dietro da tanto tempo, dalla prima volta
che ho visto i giornali di settore per
uomini e quelli per donne separati
in un binarismo di genere che non lascia
assolutamente spazio all’immaginazione.
E sui giornali per uomini
scrivevano gli uomini,
su quelli per donne, le donne,
cose da maschi, cose da femmine.
Mai nessun punto di contatto.
Mi ricordo anche qualche articolo
che usciva su questi giornali,
e i titoli che potevamo trovarci
erano più o meno questi:
“Come fare per essere una moglie
sempre sexy”,
oppure, “Cosa deve fare l’uomo
che non deve chiedere mai”.
Insomma, la sagra dello stereotipo.
Ma qui arriviamo al dunque.
Di cosa parliamo quando parliamo
stereotipi, e nello specifico,
di cosa parliamo quando parliamo
di stereotipi di genere?
Gli stereotipi di genere
sono un insieme di credenze
socialmente trasmesse e condivise
su quelli che devono essere il ruolo,
l’aspetto fisico,
le qualità morali di una persona
in base alla sua appartenenza di genere.
Lo stereotipo servirebbe per semplificare,
in un modo che poi vedremo è superficiale
quanto impreciso,
la realtà che ci circonda.
Facciamo un esempio, se io vi dico:
“bambina”,
voi in automatico abbinerete
il colore rosa ai capelli lunghi.
Se io vi dico: “Bambino”,
voi abbinerete il colore blu
e i capelli corti.
Ora, queste semplificazioni sono imprecise
perché non tengono conto dell’evoluzione
del gruppo sociale a cui si riferiscono
né del mondo che gli si sviluppa intorno.
Ma soprattutto,
queste semplificazioni non tengono conto
dell’individualità del singolo,
che è ben più importante.
Lo scopo infatti degli stereotipi
è quello di cristallizzare una determinata
categoria di persone
all’interno di una società
che però è proiettata verso il futuro,
è in continua evoluzione,
ed è proprio qua che nasce l’imprecisione
dello stereotipo.
Ci sono -
Tra gli stereotipi di genere,
i più diffusi sono sicuramente quelli
che riguardano le qualità morali
che uomini e donne dovrebbero avere
per essere ritenuti valevoli
E quindi se io penso a un uomo cosa avrò?
Avrò forza, virilità, aggressività,
anche sessuale
Se io penso a una donna, invece,
penserò a romanticismo, emotività,
passività, anche sessuale.
Queste semplificazioni creano
dei veri e propri mostri
nella nascita di quelle
che sono le relazioni
che crescono in ottica
eteronormata.
E questo avviene perché
la società patriarcale,
che si basa proprio su questi stereotipi,
ci vuol far credere che uomini e donne
così diversi sulla carta
non siano in grado di comunicare
tra di loro,
che non possano collaborare, anzi,
che debbano competere
e che gli interessi degli uni non siano
condivisibili dalle altre e viceversa.
La deriva di questa che chiameremo
“Teoria dell’incomunicabilità”
porta alla nascita di quella che si chiama
“Mascolinità tossica”,
e che affligge prepotentemente
entrambi i sessi.
Le aspettative di successo, virilità,
fama, forza, ipersessualità
che noi abbiamo nei confronti
del genere maschile
sono il comune denominatore
di questa deriva comportamentale.
La performatività è tutto,
e la performatività aumenta in tutte
quelle situazioni di collettività
in cui i partecipanti sono tutti maschi.
Pensiamo alle chat di Telegram,
dove avviene lo scambio non consensuale
di materiale intimo, per esempio.
Le donne, in quest’ottica di tossicità,
vengono percepite come il famoso
secondo sesso,
come succubi, come oggetti,
come delle prede.
La mascolinità tossica richiede un
costante allineamento
agli stereotipi di genere,
ed è questa la performatività.
Per essere performativi dobbiamo adottare
dei comportamenti
che comprendono il rinnegare
completamente le emozioni,
l’avere un’apparenza di stoicismo in
tutti gli aspetti della vita,
ma soprattutto abbracciare
la violenza
come indicatore di potere nelle relazioni
che abbiamo con il mondo che ci circonda.
Viene da sé che la deriva di questi
comportamenti porta alla nascita
di quella che si chiama
“Violenza di genere”.
E invece chi non si riconosce
in questi codici
verrà estromesso dal gruppo
e avrà dei seri problemi a integrarsi
in determinati contesti sociali,
soprattutto relazionali.
La mascolinità tossica si cura
con due cose:
con contatto e compartecipazione
perché senza contatto e partecipazione noi
continueremo a pensare che gli uomini
siano dei cacciatori che vengono da Marte,
pianeta titolato al dio della guerra,
bello ma non ci vivrei,
e che le donne siano le loro schiave,
che siano passive,
che siano delle prede.
Ecco noi dobbiamo ricominciare
a riformulare proprio il linguaggio
con cui chiamiamo le relazioni,
che è più simile a quello
di una battuta di caccia,
a quello di una guerra.
Non ci sono prede, non ci sono cacciatori,
non stiamo facendo un abbordaggio,
non è un campo di battaglia
Per riformulare questo linguaggio
dobbiamo occupare quelli che da sempre
sono stati gli spazi in cui
questi stereotipi
hanno trovato terreno fertile.
E quindi basta con magazine maschili
scritti solo da uomini.
Apriamo i magazine femminili a voci nuove
libere dagli stereotipi.
Smettiamola con i guru della seduzione,
le guide per maschi vincenti,
i decaloghi sulle donne
che devono essere sempre sensuali.
Smettiamola di credere
che le uniche reazioni valide maschili
siano quelle aggressive,
e che le uniche valide femminili
siano quelle passive.
Dobbiamo riscrivere un linguaggio
emotivo comune,
libero.
Ho fatto la sex columnist per tanti anni,
e ho raccontato la sessualità femminile
agli uomini.
E vorrei che questo diventasse normale
nella quotidianità,
in modo da non aver più bisogno
di figure professionali come la mia.
Perché ci raccontano da sempre
che uomini e donne non si comprendano
tra di loro,
e vi assicuro che non esiste
bugia più grande
che sia mai stata né scritta né detta.
Dobbiamo insegnare ai bambini
a processare le emozioni.
Liberiamo le bambine
dal senso di passività.
Comunichiamo i nostri desideri
senza vergogna, senza tabù.
Esigiamo lezioni di educazione sessuale
ed educazione al consenso
nelle scuole dei nostri figli
e delle nostre figlie.
Cerchiamo un contatto,
abbattiamo il giudizio
e cerchiamo un contatto,
perché in definitiva sarà proprio questo
a renderci persone libere.
(Applausi)